david ayers from zamboni driver and
emergency goalie available to either
team the maple leafs or the hurricanes
pressed into service as the goalie for
the hurricanes in toronto on saturday
night gave up goals on his first two
shots but then became a stone wall
helping the hurricanes beat
the toronto maple leafs and that
inspires today's draft peter king the
most memorable emergency moments in nfl
history this is broad it's as broad as
we want it to be we can look at any
angle of any emergency situation just in
the memorable emergency moments all time
and you get the first pick if you get
this trivia question right the franchise
tag window was supposed to open tomorrow
but has been pushed back to thursday
who was the first nfl quarterback to
ever be given the franchise tag the hint
is that he's in the hall of fame
uh
let me see mike i'm going to totally
draw a blank on that one i don't know
the answer to that one
i would have done the same thing it's
steve young
steve young
yeah i didn't even know it was a
franchise tag so there we go all right
for me look when i think emergency in
the national football league i think
back to
the the days of my early nfl fandom i
think of thanksgiving i think of the
cowboys i think of washington and i
think of clint longley that was the
first thing that came to mind when i saw
the draft it may not be the most popular
first pick but for me
that was the moment where i saw for the
first time something that was completely
unexpected completely off script and it
worked and dallas came back to beat
washington on thanksgiving when clint
longley came in for roger staubach and
uh eventually it was i think clint
longley beat up roger staubach which
resulted in clint longley not being in
dallas anymore but uh that is true thank
you for that thanksgiving day he was the
man and i'll never forget i never get
that throw to drew pearson uh slightly
more favorable outcome than the push off
against the vikings don't play it
control room do not play the hail mary
throw to drew pearson against the
vikings in the 75 playoffs
you know they'll find a way to play it
they're going to find a way to oh god
there it is
here we go
this is a beautiful play
i wish this
nate wright's technique is i'm going to
dive forward and flail in the direction
away from the ball that's great
technique all right what's your first
pick peter
my first pick has nothing to do with any
sort of modern reality but in 1969
christopher price really good writer in
boston wrote this in a book called the
blueprint and it's one of my favorite
nfl stories it doesn't get nearly enough
attention the patriots in training camp
1969
cut a defensive back from notre dame
named bob gladjo
so bob gladjo
came to one of the games early in 1969
and he he parties with his his friends
before the game he's out in the parking
lot having beers they walk into the
stadium it's about 20 minutes before the
game public address announcer would bob
gladjo please report to the patriots
locker room
bob gladjo so he gets up
he's half cocked and he walks to the
locker room and they say hey we just cut
john doe we need you sign this contract
you're playing today
and his friends are saying where's bob
there's no cell phones in those days and
then they look out and on the opening
kickoff
bob gladjo is in uniform
patriots uniform chasing down a kickoff
with about 16 beers in his gut
and that ladies and gentlemen
is the greatest story
of some emergency player in nfl history
you can't top that florio you know you
can't stop it i i i never heard of bob
glad joe before today that that is
definitely an emergency moment does your
flight back from vince young's pro day
count as an emergency moment i guess we
could make i could make that my second
pick i'd never thought of that this
isn't part of a bit this isn't schtick
i'm just realizing that would definitely
count as an emergency
listen i knew i knew that day i had
three hours i knew i had three hours
from the time i started the colonoscopy
prep to the first time because i this
was going to be my second time doing
this
this was go i had three hours the flight
was gonna be three hours i just didn't
count on a storm around newark
international airport and us having to
circle for 45 minutes that is where it
got very tricky
yeah the storm lighter hitting the
terminal too in a very different way all
right next pick for me
and and this this is kind of an
emergency kind of uh i i like it though
i think of just unusual things that
happened it's when uh and this is the
patriots again when they sent the
snowplow out to clear a path i mean
that's an emergency we're not gonna be
able to kick a field goal it's an
emergency they send the snowplow out don
schula loses his mind and the patriots
kick the field goal and they win the
game and they're right on cue see i i
endorse highlights like this control
room not the hail mary play there comes
the snow plow wasn't that guy a a
convict on work release wasn't that
wasn't that his story that's what he was
just up john
makes the left turn creates the spot and
there's the field goal and the patriots
win the game don schuler was not happy
no not happy at all
all right mike
round two okay 1987
it's a strike game it's the new york
giants third strike game it's the giants
against the buffalo bills jeff rutledge
has crossed the picket line for the
giants lawrence taylor has crossed the
picket line for the giants so they go to
buffalo with just a bunch of schmoes
playing
and in that game
the buffalo bills tackle who's right
across the the line from lawrence taylor
the great lawrence taylor is a truck
driver from illinois named joe schultz
and that day
joe schultz got seven penalties against
him for doing various things to lawrence
taylor and at the end of the game toward
the end of the game taylor and joe
schultz are rolling around on the ground
and taylor tries to gouge joe schultz's
eyes out and he puts his fist he tries
to put his fist through the helmet but
joe schultz has been playing world
wrestling federation against this guy
all day and so
he and and you know joe schultz got the
last laugh he was back in illinois being
a truck driver the next week but he can
always say
i handled lawrence taylor because the
buffalo bills won that scintillating
football game
six to three
i i this next one for me is one that i
can personally attest to because i was
there when it happened when i look i
keep looking at the title of the draft
the most memorable emergency moments in
nfl history super bowl 47
early in the second half the biggest
game of the year
and the lights go out in the superdome
and there was a period of time where no
one knew what the hell was happening and
in the superdome the press box was
basically stapled to the roof
we are as far away like we're the last
ones getting out if there's a reason to
get out of this place quickly we are the
last ones to get out and mike silver
your former sports illustrated colleague
now at nfl.com just declares
as loudly as he can is this a terrorist
attack which of course did nothing to
calm down the people in the press box
but we had no idea we had no idea but
the lights went out at the super bowl
and you know every once in a while
somebody from that ravens team still
throws out the idea that it was
deliberate aimed at taking the air out
of the balloon for the ravens and giving
the 49ers a chance to come back ray
lewis has pushed that theory
in the past uh it's baloney it's
nonsense because it was definitely not a
good development for the nfl but you
know what the 49ers did come back and
almost win the game during that extended
second half time that really no one was
prepared for and uh it is definitely a
memorable emergency moment there were a
lot of texts being sent where's my you
know my family was at the game
what do we do how do we get out of here
what's going on there there was a period
of two to five minutes where nobody
really knew what was happening so that
is a memorable emergency moment for the
nfl
i i'm glad i'm blissfully unaware and
you know i i i didn't think anything of
that in the time i just said well time
to go get a hot dog
it didn't really bug me too much my
third one mike is going to be that you
know when
when the new orleans saints could not
play football
in the superdome after hurricane katrina
that was you know the biggest franchise
emergency moment i've ever seen and the
one thing i'll always remember about
those emergency moments is where the
saints ended up playing they ended up
playing some in baton rouge but they
played most of their games in san
antonio and in one of these games
michael vick came to san antonio and he
just beat the the stuffing out of the uh
you know out of the uh new orleans
saints you know because he was still
with the falcons at the time and what
i'll always remember about after that
game is that all the guys in the falcons
are sitting in their locker room and
they're just shrugging their shoulders
hey it's a normal fact of life we had to
play somewhere we've never been to
before so that emergency moment was
memorable because
to me
we all thought that the saints were
moving to san antonio right around that
time so hey you better get used to your
team but luckily for them luckily for
the city of new orleans paul tagliabue
stepped in and said the saints are going
nowhere
yeah you know in a roundabout way that
that horrible disaster that was katrina
helped
create the foundation for the saints to
stay put because paul tagliabue did
insist after that that the saints were
going to be part of the rebuilding the
talk that had been rampant of a move to
san antonio ended and from that moment
they reopened the dome with the steve
gleason block punt that's memorialized
with a statue outside of the superdome
now everything changed the mood changed
the attitude changed the vibe changed
the saints that year made it to the nfc
championship they would lose to the
bears but three years after that they
win the super bowl and the bond between
saints and new orleans
is infinitely stronger than it was
pre-katrina um and and it's it they're
never leaving new orleans now and i
remember there were several years where
it was almost a foregone conclusion that
they were not long for new orleans all
right that's our draft uh is that all
three that's all three rounds i you know
there were others that i thought about i
thought about the time tony dungey
played emergency quarterback for the
steelers when he was a rookie oh that's
a good one that's a good one
and i mean he that was the only time he
played quarterback nfl he was the the
big ten
passing leader in his final year i think
for two years at the university of
minnesota and uh got a shot to play
quarterback when the the other guys went
down in that game at houston um and
that's you know stuffing games like like
the immaculate reception was technically
an emergency moment right wasn't it i
mean i kind of thought about that i
thought it was kind of like too low
hanging for like the david tyree helmet
catch that's an emergency moment i mean
games on the line season's on the line
and you make something happen but i
think it was more fun to come up with
some of this other stuff all right let's
take a break we got more pfd live still
to come we're wrapping up today before
we head to indianapolis for tuesday
wednesday thursday there's the
draft results i've got clint longley
playing in thanksgiving back in the mid
70s the patriot snowplow game the power
failure at super bowl 47 peters picks
bob gladja who i'd never heard of joe
schultz versus lawrence taylor and the
hurricane katrina forcing new orleans
saints to play anywhere but nobody's
going to vote for either one of us mike
no nobody's voting for us nobody cares
bob gladjau ladies and gentlemen we'll
back more right after this hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching make sure
to hit subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports